hello david  what do you know about zone 414  my city of robots  my androids  [Music]  companionship as rare these days  not my kind of place  the task is my daughter melissa three  weeks ago she went missing  i need you to retrieve her for me  and when you get there find jane she  might be my best creation  so unique  welcome to the zoo you help me find  melissa  so you're a friend of hers right i don't  need any more trouble  what kind of trouble  i appreciate the fact that jane is your  tour guide  don't trust her vit is paying you to  find the girl  find the girl get your money and leave  you look but you do not  see they can feel  pain you know in their own way  they scream  i said don't move  you have a murderer in the zone  stay right there  what's more human than fear  you